E
R RE
TALK ABOUT THE MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODY THAT WE NEED NOW, NOT
TODAY, NOT YESTERDAY, WE NEED
IT THIS MOMENT.
WE NEEDTHE PILL, THE
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES AND NEED
THE TESTING RIGHT NOW.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IN SOUTH AFRICA IT LEVELED OFF.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE INFECTED.
GET THE BOOSTERS OUT THERE NOW
BUT NOT BY LECTURING.
I AGREE, LET'S NOT DEMONIZE
PEOPLE OR MANDE PEOP.
LET'TALK TO PELE ANGET
THOSSHOTS INTO DOCT'S OFCES WHIE
BEEN SAYING ALSO FOR WEEKS.
LET ME HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
LET ME HAVE THAT CONVERSATION,
NOT A POLITICIAN.
>> Harris: IF YOU ARE HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH YOUR CTOR
IT ONLY MAKES SENSE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MIGHT
HAVE TO HELP OUT TO HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO HANDLE THAT ON SITE
FOR DOCTORS BUT DO WHATEVER IT
TAKES.
QUICKLY THE ARMY HAS ME UP
WITH WHAT COULD BE SOMETHING
THAT CAN HIT ALL THE VARIANTS.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE A SINGLE
VACCINE THAT IS -- A CAVEAT.
IT WAS NOT TESTED ON THE
OMICRON VARIANT.
DR. SIEGEL.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THIS UP.
I WANT TO PLAY OUT SOMETHING WE
BOTH LOVE.
THE MITARY.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THIS.
THEIR INFECTIOUS DISEASE
DIVISION AT WALTER REED AND THE
ARMY INFECTIOUS DISEASES IS TOP
OF THE WORLD.
THEY ARE AS GOOD AS THE CDC OR
BETTER AND QUIETLY RESEARCHING
A VACCINE THAT USES A SOCCER
BALL TYPE PROTEIN.
HASN'T BEEN TESTED AGAINST
OMICRON BUT VERY EFFECTIVE
AGAINST ALL VARIANTS.
STILL IN EARLY TRIALS.
IS MAY BE THE GAME ANGER
FOR THE VACCINE WHERE YOU JUST
NEED THIS CCINE AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO KEEP RECONFURING FOR
EMERGING VARIANTS.
THIS RESEARCH VERY EXCITING,
STILL EARLY.
GOING INTO MIDDLE STAGE TRIALS
NOW WITH HUMANS.
>> Harris: WALTER REED AND THE
MILITARY CRITICAL.
WE'LL KEEP AN EYE ON THIS PART
OF OUR COVERAGE.
DR. SIEGEL.